ashle stand no don't touch it isn't it
flashed me it's the end hi there i'm
aria and as the camming industry
continues to thrive I figure what better
way to learn more about this unique and
fascinating profession than by spending
the day with a cab girl
I'm meeting Scarlett a cam girl who like
many others earns money by performing
online in nude cam shows Scarlett is
also a vegan and animal lover who owns a
dog named ash I started camping in April
of last year so I've been camping almost
a year now a year after I eventually
realized that a pet store might not be
the most appropriate place to discuss
camming we head back to Scarlett's
apartment what is this oh it's just my
presence that I get you get present I do
get present I have no clue you want try
to guess what does it feel like would
you say what do you think it's a pony
pony it's a pony I put that on my
wishlist you got me what are some stuff
you've got on your wish list ah my desk
in my room and my carpet and my mattress
topper was from so basically your entire
house yeah everything is there a chance
is gonna be inappropriate possibly Oh
actually this is not dirty we're good
fantastic let's see it's a choker
it's a choker yes a really cute one I
definitely knew what that was
that's a bath mat check any back oh yeah
Rocky you wanna come here give it a
whirl how was that for you what would
you get that on a scale of 1 to 10
that's a good that's good number
Scarlett Ben takes us into her bedroom
where she will usually cam from hey this
is a Lovins this is what a lot of girls
use on chatter B basically this goes
inside you with the tail hanging out so
it connects to your laptop and when you
get tips on the website it makes this
buzz so depending on how much you tip is
how long it buzzes for and how hard she
also shows more of the toys she'll often
use oncam nipple clamps
oh my
handcuffs whips this is like a very
dirty version of Mary Poppins purse yes
I have a ball gag it's like a oh and a
typical amps as well how did you get
into County when I was 15 my dad kicked
me out because he wanted to live with
his girlfriend at the time who didn't
like me and so I had to drop out of
school to get a job and I was working as
a dishwasher I was working like 10 to 14
hours a day and I knew I wanted to do
camming but I waited until like a couple
months after I turned 18 I figured I
would just try this and see how it goes
and it kind of saved my life because I
was so miserable doing what I was doing
a lot of people think that camming is
just only like having a webcam and then
just masturbating but for me for
instance it's about like building a
community and bonding with people and
getting to know people like offline as
well growing up for me I was bullied and
something that I found was helpful was
to be in chat rooms online and places
where I could talk to other people
online so this is why I enjoy doing what
I do so much because I'm still doing
what I used to do like I'm just talking
to people in a chat room what's it like
for your roommate how'd that work well I
had to make sure she was okay before she
moved in with what I did and luckily she
is and she's supportive of me if for her
probably it sounds like I'm just in a
very enthusiastic Skype call soon after
scarlet informs her followers that she's
going live so right now people are just
like realizing that I'm live and they'll
start coming in slowly this person says
well hey aria how has the day been going
so polite my day is going swell so this
how a typical show goes yeah so this is
still like warming up we already have
almost there gonna be people watching
Wow
scarlet currently makes up to $700 per
session with an audience averaging
around 2,000 to 3,000 viewers do you
want to spank me or do you want to be
spanked these are questions I didn't
think I was gonna be ready for today
how many of that three god damn it Ryan
all right have a good day to have a good
day hey those people are very friendly
yeah they are but a lot of rooms are not
like we're it's just all demands and
dirty things a lot of the time as well
it's just like people coming in for
conversation as the show progresses more
requests specifically for me start to
come in if you want to flash your feet
okay oh oh
Nordic guy says can we tip to get his
clothes off there's gonna be no nudity
jacker but luckily as I knew I couldn't
get inappropriate on camera I already
had something up my sleeve you're gonna
get something even better than a new
show in a little bit I'm really really
excited for this and she should be
because since I didn't want to let her
viewers down I preemptively arranged for
a local theatre company to come join me
in the camming industry's first ever
live theatrical performance of the
classic 1980 musical spectacular the
music odd I've always wanted to do
Lemay's and not had a chance to do it
before so I'm really excited to really
nail this version here that we're doing
today 2,000 viewers right now they want
to see if so we're gonna give it a show
they're gonna get something we can't
mess this up
[Music]
so how did you like the show I am loved
it I thought it was incredible
my viewers loved it they were writing in
the chat the whole time how much they
loved it it's not always sexual a lot of
people come for the entertainment value
as well and that's what happened today
people were joining to see the
entertainment of what was going on with
the theater performance you imagine just
going to a room and just jerking off for
hours on end like that's boring you get
bored and you just leave eventually I
have the entertainment value so you come
you stay for my personality and then you
also jerk off sometimes camming is more
than meets the eye people don't
understand that there's a lot more that
goes into it
some days I tried to think and I'm just
like if I could be doing anything else
what would I be doing and I can't think
of anything else because I just I always
come back to camming like I love Kamy
and I love video making yeah this is one
of my favorite times streaming as well
this is the coolest thing I think I've
ever done on cam everyone should check
it out it's not a lonely thing because a
lot of people assume like only lonely
guys go on there but it's it's for
everyone so I'm gonna do this as long as
I can as long as it's making like a
sustainable income and I'm happy doing
it then I'm gonna do it there's nothing
else I'd rather be doing
[Music]
[Applause]